all i know is like being broke being  filipino but yet  so entertained  so full in the stomach because there was  so much food there was an abundance of  foods quite the spread mom  that's for dinner  laughter everyone's funny everyone's  funny are we putting anything in the box  dad just love and i'm putting in viagra  that's a different kind of love strong  all night long and you're creating and  then when you're broke you go within to  entertain right so it's like that's why  filipino food is like such a thing like  they always want to give food because  they want to engage and talk take a full  boron i made it just for you oh junior  save room for my empanadas hey look we  can't afford cable but we can talk  eat boy nobody's eating my empanadas  it's my special recipe oh no these are  the best mama tea oh by the way my son  can dance dance joseph  empanadas my favorite